brandon bilac on the mound for the
astros this evening 2-0 with a 1.76 cra
here's trevor story eight-game hitting
streak
he's waiting for an o2 here it is
swinging in a mess got him on a good
slider good morning good afternoon and
good night to trevor story left-hander
kyle freeland going for the colorado
rockies runners on the corners now with
two away here's carlos correa
he ropes one down the line fair ball
towards the corner bregman in to
be waved around here comes guerrielle
the relay throw will not be made two
nothing astros on a carlos correa
ringing double
kyle tucker payoff pitch to tucker
strike three called at the knees on the
outside corner and kyle freeland has his
first strikeout mile straw at the plate
there's a good changeup swing and a miss
and back to back strikeouts for kyle
freeland here in the second time for
trevor story a strikeout his first time
and that ball's crushed to left and i'm
glad he hung around
that is trevor's seventh of the year and
it's two to one nine game history for
trevor and that was
close to the train tracks
here's alex bregman
that ball hit into right center field
breckman continues his on base streak
and he is going to think about two
getting the ball back in is garrett
hampson but not before bregman has a
stand-up double here's yuli guriel
singled his first time up
on the ground towards the whole story
diving stop no play uli
back to back base hits he continues his
incredible hitting against the rockies
that was a phenomenal a b and now has to
face carlos correa
on the ground to auronado backhands on a
couple of hops and throws out correa for
the final out astros a couple of hits
two men left on base still lead 2-1
here's aronado
falls driven to right field that sends
springer back he's on the warning track
turns around and makes the catch right
in front of the wall
and there's one out
ball hit pretty well the left center
field but straw on the move so is tucker
and those two guys converge and tucker
puts it away for out number two so two
outs base is cleared for rymel tapia
towards short correa
and brandon belak has his first one two
three inning and kyle's a one out base
runner here's mile straw he struck out
swinging his first time up
he's around a bun bunch one to murphy
murphy's thinking about second base and
he is safe all around that throw pulls
story off the bag
murphy went for the force out at second
instead of trying to get straw going
down to first and it costs the rockies
and out here's garneau right-handed
batter and the pitch from freeland
chopper to the left side nolan has it
goes to mcmahon at second for one on to
first for the double play
and kyle freeland gets his major league
high eighth double play
and no damage done in the fourth
george springer the leadoff hitter
against kyle freeland
springer a single and a grounder to two
swag and a miss came back and got him
again going a little softer with a
breaking pitch kyle gets his third
strikeout abraham toro lined to third
and grounded to third
that's a great play by mcmahon out at
first
what a play by ryan mcmahon
no better feeling as an infielder than
you dive and then you come up with the
ball and now you go i got him i got him
right here i could i could throw him out
by a step yeah
well the guy at the plate now alex
bregman 2-2
and a great pitch by freeland
two more strikeouts and a one two three
fifth given some runs so story at first
one out for nolan arenado flat out to
deep right his last time
on the ground slowly hit to correa he
will get to altuve for one and they turn
the double play on arenato brandon belak
gets through six innings for the first
time in his young career if v lack
allows one run over six innings that'll
improve that number and the astros will
turn it over to their bullpen the lefty
brooks raley so daniel murphy their
first baseman lays things off
called third strike outside corner that
will not make murphy happy
no story a home run a walk he's also
struck out a head002 here and a swing
and a miss there nice job by james after
the walk to get the strikeout of trevor
story to get through the eighth the
astros lead 2-1 as we head to the ninth
inning raymel tapia left-handed hitter
the last hope for the rockies tonight
fly ball center field playable for mile
straw
and blake taylor picks up his first
major league save after an initial hit
by charlie blackmon three fly ball outs
to center field and the astros hold on
to win it two to one